laissé à l'abandon lors du rachat du
château d'alincourt l'orangerie a été
acquise par la mairie en 2015
c'est treillage en bois fait main mais
surtout son plafond peint avec des
motifs de feuillage en font un lieu
unique
ce bâtiment donc à ce côté atypique et
original c'est que c'est que c'est un
bâtiment quasiment unique voilà donc une
orange une orangerie équipe aménagé de
cette façon il n'existe pas d'autres en
france donc c'est ce qui est aussi un
petit peu séduit les membres du jury qui
ont sélectionné c'est cet orange reid
par l'intermédiaire de la fondation du
patrimoine
mais le monument historique est mal en
point il y a quelques années la poutre
centrale s'est écroulée à cause des
intempéries
des travaux ont donc été réalisés par la
municipalité pour sécuriser l'orangerie
la rénovation est cependant loin d'être
terminée il faudrait un million et demi
d'euros pour la remettre en état
pour commencer par refaire toute la
toiture qui est une toiture un peu à la
mansart en ardoise donc c'est déjà par
ça qu'il faut commencer pour la mettre
totalement hors d'eau et la senior
complètement
ensuite il faut il ya une reprise totale
de l'intérieur
la municipalité voudrait que l'orangerie
deviennent par la suite un lieu culturel
c'est orangerie qui permettra donc une
fois qu'elle sera rénovée de de
l'affecter principalement usages
culturels donc en faire un lieu
d'exposition en faire un lieu de concert
un lieu des changes un lieu de
conférences
voilà donc
tout à vocation culturelle la durée des
travaux dépendra des sommes d'argent
récoltées lors du loto ainsi que des
donations de mécènes mais la mairie
estime qu'il faudra cinq à sept ans
avant que l'orangerie du château d'anet
cours puissent de nouveau accueillir du
public